y el sitio de abril de 2020 en los
ciudadanos checos pudieron volver a
hacer cosas como jugar al fútbol en
parques o incluso hacer algunos viajes
dentro del país república checa- es el
primer país europeo que ya ha presentado
una estrategia para acabar con el
confinamiento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
por supuesto que todavía queda un largo
camino para acabar con el coronavirus
pero en este país han conseguido el
primer gran objetivo aplanar la curva
durante este mes de abril república
checa- va a hacer una transición de lo
que hasta ahora ha sido una cuarentena
total a lo que llaman una cuarentena
inteligente pero y cómo han conseguido
este éxito qué es eso de la cuarentena
inteligente y qué lecciones pueden sacar
otros países en este vídeo que por
cierto ha sido posible gracias a sur
shark vpn te lo vamos a contar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
chequia o república checa es un país que
apenas sale en los medios de
comunicación a no ser que consideres por
un medio de comunicación en ese caso
pensarás que praga es algo así como el
nuevo nueva york- porque es y chequia es
algo así como el hollywood del
entretenimiento para adultos
[Música]
pero hay muchas cosas más que hacen que
este país merezca un vídeo en visual
político y si hablamos de su victoria en
la lucha contra la pandemia del sars
coronavirus 2 para que os hagáis una
idea en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo república checa- tiene 5 mil
700 infectados y 119 muertos se trata de
uno de los pocos países que realmente
puede decir que ha aplanado la curva
todo esto explica que sean el primer
país de europa en aprobar una estrategia
de salida de la cuarentena
[Música]
y otros países como austria o dinamarca
también están aplicando planes similares
pero los checos han sido los primeros
sin embargo esto no es la única buena
noticia en el aspecto económico este
país también tiene mucho de lo que
presumir por el momento atentos el paro
sólo ha subido al 5 por ciento habéis
oído bien tras un mes de 40 en la
república checa está en un 5 por ciento
de tasa de desempleo en otras palabras
que si comparamos la república checa-
con otros países como italia o españa es
como hablar de la noche y el día y os
preguntaréis que han hecho también en
este país seguro que alguno estará
pensando en república sé que se tienen
que gastar una fortuna en sanidad pues
lo cierto es que no atentos a esta
gráfica
aquí podéis ver el gasto en sanidad en
relación al pib de nuevo tanto españa
como italia gasta más en sanidad que
república checa y no los checos tampoco
son millonarios en términos de teide per
cápita tanto los españoles como los
italianos son más ricos a estas alturas
alguno estará pensando que vamos a
hablar maravillas del gobierno checo
verdad su primer ministro debe de ser un
genio una especie de cruce entre
churchill nelson mandela y hielo más
pues nada de eso atentos en los casos de
corrupción suben la presión sobre el
primer ministro checo habéis oído bien
la noticia dice casos de corrupción en
plural porque lo cierto es que el primer
ministro checo
andrei davis es algo así como el
berlusconi bohemio multimillonario dueño
de varios medios de comunicación y hasta
las cejas de casos de corrupción y todo
esto lo sé porque da la casualidad de
que yo vivo en praga desde hace seis
años es decir que todo lo que os voy a
cantar hoy lo he vivido en mis propias
carnes así que la pregunta que hoy nos
hacemos es cómo
es posible que república checa- esté
empezando a volver a la normalidad qué
es lo que han hecho bien o dicho de otra
forma que han hecho tan mal en otros
países como de nuevo españa o italia y
lo que es más importante que es eso de
la 40 inteligente lo terminarán copiando
otros países significa que los que
vivimos en república checa ya podemos
salir de casa sin problemas pues a esta
pregunta os voy a responder ya mismo no
por el momento la mejor forma de luchar
contra el coronavirus es quedándonos en
casa para evitar contagiarnos y qué
podemos hacer en casa pues obviamente
entrar en internet
estos días el tráfico en internet se ha
disparado incluso youtube ha tenido que
reducir la calidad de los vídeos para
responder al subidón de visitas y esto
qué significa pues que los hackers están
haciendo su agosto estafas filtraciones
de datos y robo de privacidad nunca
había sido tan peligroso navegar por
internet como ahora pero tranquilos
existe una vacuna contra los hackers y
esa es conectarse internet a través de
una vpn como surfear
[Música]
es una vpn fantástica por muchas razones
seguro que todos habéis caído alguna vez
en una de esas páginas web de spam que
intentan estafar a dos con popups a este
tipo de prácticas se les llama phishing
pues bien sûr shark tiene una
herramienta que se llama clean web y que
bloquea todos estos popup si todos esos
enlaces que pueden ser un auténtico
peligro
[Música]
pero no sólo eso con una única cuenta de
surf shark podéis registrar todos los
dispositivos que queráis el móvil la
tablet el portátil el ordenador de
sobremesa no hay ningún límite de
dispositivos y como siempre tenemos una
oferta muy especial para todos vosotros
que seguís visual polític básicamente si
usáis el código político terminado en
acá tendréis un 83 por ciento de
descuento más un mes extra totalmente
gratis es más podéis probar sus arts
durante los primeros 30 días sin
compromiso en la descripción
os dejo los enlaces y dicho todo esto
ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
y lo mejor de dos mundos antes de hablar
del coronavirus tenemos que hablar de la
sanidad pública y si lo sé es un debate
que levanta pasiones si veis este vídeo
desde eeuu habréis oído todo tipo de
opiniones al respecto algunos políticos
dicen que quieren una sanidad al estilo
europeo
otros políticos dicen que eso es
comunismo al otro lado del charco en
europa también tenemos un montón de
debates sobre la sanidad pública y
muchos pensaréis que sólo existen dos
modelos de sanidad o es pública o es
privada es decir o bien garantizamos que
todo el mundo tenga acceso a la sanidad
o bien dejamos que se la pague quien
pueda sin embargo como siempre decimos
en visual política el está en los
detalles es verdad todos los países
europeos garantizan el acceso universal
a la sanidad ahora bien cada país tiene
sistemas totalmente distintos y podemos
hablar de dos grandes modelos el sistema
beveridge y el sistema smart
el sistema beveridge es el que tenemos
en países como españa o reino unido en
este modelo el estado se encarga de
absolutamente todo por supuesto que
también existen seguros médicos privados
pero la mayoría de los ciudadanos
utilizan la sanidad pública y esta
sanidad está controlada al cien por cien
desde la administración bien sea
regional o central es decir que los
médicos son empleados públicos y el
gobierno es quien decide cuántos
hospitales se construyen dónde y cómo
por ejemplo vamos a poner que yo tengo
un problema en el estómago pues bien si
viviera en españa tendría que ir al
centro de salud que me han asignado ahí
tendría que pedir una cita con mi médico
de cabecera que también se me ha sido
asignado desde el estado y os
preguntaréis funciona bien este sistema
pues la respuesta es que si no funciona
mal tanto reino unido como españa como
dinamarca tienen hospitales de calidad
ahora bien este sistema tiene dos
problemas el primero es que normalmente
implica tener unas listas de espera muy
largas y lo segundo es que apenas tienes
libertad para elegir el médico si veis
este vídeo desde españa
seguramente pensaréis que este es el
precio a pagar por tener una cobertura
sanitaria universal verdad pues lo
cierto es que no existe otro sistema un
sistema que de hecho es el más habitual
en toda europa hablamos del sistema
bismarck
[Música]
el sistema bismarck es el que tienen en
países como alemania o república checa
en estos países por supuesto que también
hay sanidad pública pero no se gestiona
desde el estado y quien gestiona la
sanidad pública entonces pues hablamos
de agencias de seguros por ejemplo vamos
a volver a mi problema de estómago en
este caso ya no iría al centro de salud
que me han asignado sino que tendría que
elegir un hospital o un centro de salud
aquí en praga por ejemplo es muy normal
y técnicas pequeñitas donde hay uno o
dos doctores especializados en una rama
muy concreta tenemos pues una clínica de
gastroenterólogos de urólogos de
traumatólogos y lo primero que me van a
pedir cuando llegue es que les traiga mi
tarjeta del seguro y es el seguro el que
va a pagar el tratamiento en el caso de
república checa podemos elegir entre
siete aseguradoras públicas y bien digo
aseguradoras públicas porque aunque la
sanidad no se gestiona desde el estado
las agencias de seguros tampoco son
empresas privadas son un híbrido entre
fundaciones sin ánimo de lucro y
empresas estatales es algo parecido a lo
que eran las cajas de ahorros en españa
es decir que compitan entre ellas son
independientes pero a la vez tienen
precios regulados en otras palabras que
el sistema bismarck tiene lo mejor de
ambos mundos por un lado el estado
garantiza la cobertura universal pero a
la vez hay un mercado y un mercado con
competencia las aseguradoras compiten
por ofrecer más cobertura y a la vez los
hospitales compiten entre ellos para
captar pacientes por ejemplo gracias a
este sistema para mí es muy fácil
encontrar médicos que hablen en ingles
inter me que dejar una fortuna en una
clínica privada porque como os podéis
imaginar yo tengo un checo nivel tarzán
y ya sé lo que no estaréis preguntando
ahora y todo esto que tiene que ver con
el coronavirus
[Música]
pues pensadlo bien en un sistema donde
todo está gestionado por el estado los
hospitales apenas tienen autonomía qué
pasó en españa pues que como el gobierno
no se tomó en serio la amenaza de
coronavirus casi ningún hospital pudo
comprar mascarillas ni respiradores a
fin de cuentas es el gobierno el que los
compra web que decide lo que se compra
en los países con sistema bismarck sin
embargo los hospitales y las clínicas
son independientes así que han podido
buscar proveedores de material sanitario
desde enero pero esperad un momento
porque esta no es la única diferencia
ahora mismo vamos a ver como república
checa- ha gestionado la pandemia
desde taiwán con amor si algún día
visitéis fraga hay una cosa que os va a
llamar la atención seguramente os
encontraréis con muchas banderas del
tíbet y diréis que tiene que ver el
tíbet con chequia pues lo cierto es que
desde el año 2018 praga tiene como
alcalde al hombre más odiado por el
régimen chino y no es ninguna broma
el señor es de fritz que por cierto es
uno de los pocos políticos europeos del
partido pirata lleva años mostrando su
animadversión hacia beijing y creedme en
un país como república checa- esto puede
ser un problema
braga recibe más de 600.000 turistas
chinos al año y no sólo hablamos de
turismo por ejemplo aun crédit es una de
las empresas de crédito al consumo más
populares en china y su fundador es
peter kellner que es el hombre más rico
de toda república checa
durante años china ha hecho un montón de
inversiones en este país y este es sólo
un ejemplo
en algún momento china llegó a
considerar la república checa- como su
puerta de entrada para hacer negocios en
europa sin embargo esta luna de miel ha
llegado a su fin y si las relaciones con
china iban mal el 9 de febrero se
terminaron de romper con esta noticia
[Música]
ya es oficial el gobierno checo prohíbe
los vuelos directos con china la razón
para prohibir los vuelos os la podéis
imaginar el coronavirus pero por
evidente que pueda sonar nos ahora en
aquel momento fue una decisión muy
polémica de hecho república checa- fue
el único país de europa en prohibir los
vuelos con china incluso la propia o ms
estaba en contra atentos a lo que decían
en febrero de 2020
[Música]
el jefe de la oms dice que no es
necesario prohibir vuelos para combatir
el virus de china y diréis pero que el
gobierno checo no escuchó los consejos
de la o ms pues por esto
el alcalde de praga da las gracias a
taiwán por compartir materiales de
respuesta contra el kobe 19 exacto
durante todo este año
taiwán ha estado compartiendo
información con republica checa
básicamente al romper sus lazos con
beijing praga se ha hermanado con taipei
la capital de taiwán y estas relaciones
diplomáticas han sido muy útiles en
estos momentos el 7 de marzo praga
recibió toda la documentación todos los
datos y analíticas que habían estado
recopilando en taiwán sobre cómo habían
respondido a la crisis de coronavirus
por ejemplo en contra de lo que
recomendaba la o ms taiwán aconsejaba
que los ciudadanos llevaran mascarillas
también se explicaba cómo hacer tests
masivos de forma efectiva si lo pensáis
desde un punto de vista político podemos
entender una pandemia como un problema
de oferta y demanda de repente la
demanda de atención médica se dispara
hasta saturar la oferta así que cuál es
el primer paso que tenemos que dar pues
efectivamente reducir la demanda y por
eso esta noticia es tan importante
[Música]
[Aplausos]
debido a la expansión del coronavirus el
gobierno ha declarado el estado de
emergencia el 12 de marzo de 2020 con
medidas preventivas más estrictas en
aquel momento república checa tenía 116
casos confirmados de kobe 19 para que os
hagáis una idea españa no decretó el
estado de alarma hasta haber pasado los
5 mil infectados gracias a haber actuado
antes
la cuarentena checa ha sido mucho más
suave pero más efectiva por ejemplo a
diferencia de españa aquí los parques
han estado abiertos durante todo el
tiempo y los chicos han podido dar
pequeños paseos siempre y cuando
llevarán una mascarilla como ésta en la
mayor parte de los casos las mascarillas
eran muy sencillas o incluso hechas en
casa también se ha permitido salir a la
calle con bufandas el objetivo de la
mascarilla no es evitar contagiarse sino
evitar contagiar por supuesto que si tú
te cubres la boca y la nariz con algo
como esto no garantiza que no vaya a
salir ningún virus pero ya es una
pequeña barrera que reduce las
probabilidades de contagio de nuevo el
objetivo no es acabar con la demanda
sino reducir la y en este caso cada
medida cuenta el tema de las mascarillas
tan importante que incluso los
presentadores de los telediarios daban
los informativos con la mascarilla
puesta
pero lo más importante es que al haber
empezado antes la curva de contagiados
no ha crecido tan rápido atentos a esta
gráfica
aquí podéis ver la curva de infectados
de españa' comparada con la de república
checa así es como república checa- ha
conseguido reducir la demanda de camas
de hospital pero y qué pasa con la
oferta pues obviamente es imprescindible
ampliar la es decir conseguir hacerse
con mascarillas quirúrgicas respiradores
y todos los equipos para proteger al
personal sanitario así es como el
gobierno checo se ha lanzado como loco a
buscar proveedores en china y si en este
caso tenemos que ser justos porque al
igual que ha pasado en otros países como
españa república checa también ha sido
víctima de alguna que otra estafa
el 80% de los tests rápidos de kobe 19
que compró república checa- no funcionan
sin embargo esta no ha sido la única
medida en todo momento chequia ha
contado con su sociedad civil por
ejemplo el instituto checo de ciencias
de la computación ha desarrollado su
propio modelo de respirador para
imprimirlo en 3-d incluso desde el
propio gobierno han estado ayudando a
los internautas para que también
pudieran imprimir sus respiradores con
impresoras de 3d domésticas y esto es
algo muy curioso porque por ejemplo en
españa también hay gente con impresoras
en 3-d y también se han organizado por
internet el problema pues que por alguna
razón que no alcanzo a entender las
autoridades lo han rechazado
madrid- dice no a la solidaridad de los
impresores 3-d tras días aceptando las
pantallas protectoras contra el
coronavirus fabricadas en casa la
comunidad de madrid' ha cambiado de
parecer sin dar un motivo y por supuesto
todo esto hay que añadirle la
comunicación el gobierno checo ha estado
informando a los ciudadanos en todo
momento a través de folletos sms y por
supuesto esta página web en la página
web del gobierno checo se podía ver en
todo momento el número de infectados el
número de muertos clasificados por
regiones por edades y por sexo
pero no sólo eso también había un
inventario de mascarillas respiradores
equipamiento sanitario etcétera
comparada ahora la página checa con la
página del gobierno de españa' que ni
siquiera tiene gráficas indexadas es
decir las gráficas son un archivo jpg
que ni siquiera se puede traducir con
google translate por si no hablas
español ya sé que es un pequeño detalle
pero indica la diferencia de mentalidad
entre un país y otro gracias a todas
estas medidas república checa- no sólo
ha evitado la saturación de los
hospitales sino que también está
empezando a ayudar a otros países
[Música]
república checa- va a tratar a seis
pacientes de kobe 19 de francia en un
hospital universitario para ayudar a
aliviar la presión al sistema sanitario
francés por cierto que este caso de
solidaridad entre países europeos no es
único
alemania y luxemburgo también están
tratando a pacientes franceses y
probablemente vamos a ver muchos más
casos de este tipo a medida que más
países consigan frenar la pandemia pero
la pregunta la pregunta que todos nos
estamos haciendo ahora es y ahora cuál
es el siguiente paso se van a levantar
todas las restricciones de golpe ha
terminado la cuarentena la respuesta es
que no en cualquier momento podría
volver un segundo brote y se perdería
todo lo que se ha conseguido así que la
estrategia que está probando república
checa- y que probablemente se termine
copiando en otros países es lo que
llaman la cuarentena inteligente
i
república checa a lanzar a la cuarentena
inteligente los datos de los operadores
móviles y los pagos de las tarjetas de
crédito serán accesibles para la
autoridad de higiene regional para
monitorizar los movimientos de los
nuevos infectados de coronavirus
identificarlos y aislar los sólo
requiere que los ciudadanos lo acepten y
den su consentimiento para ser
monitorizados básicamente el gobierno
todavía no puede testar a toda la
población así que lo que van a hacer es
utilizar los datos del teléfono móvil y
tarjetas de crédito vamos a imaginar que
por ejemplo yo hago un test de kobe 19 y
doy positivo en este caso los médicos me
van a preguntar si quiero dar acceso al
gobierno a mi teléfono móvil por
supuesto todo esto de forma voluntaria
es decir que podría decir que no pero en
el caso de que les deje y les dé permiso
podrían utilizar la geolocalización y
los datos de mi móvil para identificar a
todas las personas con las que he estado
en los últimos días es muy probable que
sin saberlo les haya contagiado así que
tanto yo como todos los posibles
contagiados estaríamos obligados a hacer
cuarentena de esta forma sólo los que
están contagiados se tienen
y el resto podría hacer una vida más o
menos normal
[Música]
y por supuesto aquí entra el debate
ético porque todo esto tiene un riesgo
muy grande consiste en regalarle toda mi
privacidad al gobierno así que ahora la
pregunta es para vosotros estaríais
dispuestos a que el gobierno pueda
registrar los movimientos a cambio de
evitar un confinamiento masivo creéis
que vuestro país también terminará
haciendo cuarentenas inteligentes que os
parecería podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y nada más
como siempre recordad que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a visual política y darle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle al like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]